by the way you want some more weed I
just love number two you know if you
want
one enough uh I don't know how high
you're trying to get
oh oh this is my last [__] of the day so
I'm going in this is last year of the
day well not really I mean blocks we
don't smoke though this would be the
last one this is that's your first one
allowed
your second what time are you
it's 3 15.
315 yeah
I wouldn't what they like my what what
they like my what
will you smoke a joint instead of eating
a meal sometimes
I gotta smoke before I eat
so you won't replace like a meal with a
[__] joint like instead of eating on
the smoke because some people do that
with cigarettes
they'll have a cigarette instead of
eating yeah they like smoke cigarette
before they eat this [__] nah they'll
have a cigarette because it kind of
suppresses their appetite so people who
are like fat well they probably
shouldn't be smoking
but if you're like um you're like you
know like if pinky wanted hey man we
love fat people
just to let y'all know that my mom's a
fat white lady shout out to her yeah my
mama fat hey man hey the good ones are
big baby the good ones are shout out to
your mom
um now you can have a cigarette and it
will replace a meal yeah yeah
that's not a terrible idea
what about video games do you game yeah
what are you into all right now I'll
just be on PC oh so you're serious I
feel like if someone tells me they got a
PC that means that they they got a whole
they're serious
I like GTA
you'll be on like any servers on there
doing the cosplay
right now the serve that I'd be in a lot
the most I've been [__] called true
story true story in that server do you
have to be on the mic doing role playing
yeah type [__] I don't really be
streaming this [__] I don't do that [__]
do they know it's you there's a few
people now knowing me but I really
bought like my homeboys like what's your
username now what am I using no don't
say it but it's not like young nudie
1000 is it I thought no you know so
crying ain't got no picture on my [__]
so a lot of people probably see it don't
even think of me
you got a Discord yeah oh you're [__]
into it Bud yeah I'll be I I still got
nowhere I go I might not be screaming
but I know what's going on you're in yo
you you've never done um twitch where
you play games and your fans can watch
yeah I did that's it you know like
there's people getting really rich off
of that I know like T Grizzly is [__]
might as well change this occupation
they just put out a great mixtape with
Skillet baby but he's making like 100
Grand a month so again that my um
T-Pain makes like two that makes it hard
so T-pain have you seen T-Pain he'd be
on Twitch playing all kind of wild [__]
you should get on that twitch bro but
you know you also might get canceled
because you're live
like I couldn't do twitch because I'd be
[__] up and I'd say some wild [__]
that one only all right you over expose
yourself yeah maybe in like 10 years you
know that'd be true yeah like you that's
the one thing is like you go on lives
it's live you can't ain't no edits you
can't hear me yeah yeah so GTA what is
your uh like
if you let's say you break character on
the mic is there repercussions for that
because you're doing the role playing so
you like talking like yo what's up give
me your [__] money bro
hey bro we gotta go bust this Mission at
the jewelry store uh yeah I don't know
about that [__] like that yeah because I
was T Grizzly told me that in his server
if you break character that kill you
oh damn they're like smoke you in the
game and then if you break character I
think like more than three times you get
kicked off the server for life oh oh
some [__] like that oh breaking
character like let [__] know who
you with like oh you talking about other
character type [__] no you can't be like
hey bro what the [__] man I [__]
taking a getting a drink no if you're on
a mission you gotta be like oh [__] yeah
let's let's get to the [__] Ops bro
oh yeah what you mean like that RP and
[__] all the way yeah type [__] yeah oh
[__] I guess so [__] I RP and [__] what
you know I come you know
that's all I do have you done the uh the
Oculus delicious with the little things
no I ain't did that [__] it's pretty
crazy
um
they need to make some [__] where you
can like feel and [__] they do yeah they
got it there you go
I already got like you know like you get
the gloves they got [__] making
porns for the gloves damn yeah it's
crazy oh boy I know everybody go ahead
of that [__] the thing about the
the uh the headset with the porn is cool
and [__] but like
a lot of selection right now yeah yeah
like I had blue face put on the thing
and he he told me to put on a porno
pulse hanging with blue face watching
porno on a [__] on an Oculus
[Music]
but he looked down and he was like bro
my dick is pink so look don't check this
out I don't hear about that [__] about
that fair enough look look check this
out
you have been to the middle version yeah
I walked around a little I have an
Oculus
now I've been can you take [__] in that
[__] like take stuff yeah like
you crappy saying they'd be like like
it'd be real money [__] going on in the
[__] can you can you take [__]
in that number I could you rob someone
yeah
I'm sure you could
people be robbing that's it of course
taking people real money I mean it's
have you heard a [__] cryptocurrency
this [__] guy I'll be saying like the
virtual [__] people walking around and
[__] and [__] well I tell you this some
lady claimed she was virtually
um sexually harassed in the metaverse
she said her her Avatar was sexually
harassed by a group of men what and she
like filed a complaint and made this
thing on Instagram or she felt violated
and it's like your avatar you're sitting
at home alone with some goggles on they
[__] Avatar is not a [__] thing
like some I don't even care but I think
you could Rob people someone for living
this [__] you you probably couldn't like
put the mask on and you know virtually
Rob them yet I'm sure that's coming but
there's other ways to rob people I'm
just saying crappy saying they'd be you
know move dealing with real money inside
this [__] Snoop Dogg owns a plot of land
that what I'm saying like [__] like that
like what the [__] like if people not
got done having like you know like
virtual reality chat type [__] yeah like
that what I'm saying and they got down
you know
yeah I mean listen
I haven't dived all the way in well you
need to dive in it [__] because
I want to know I'm afraid if I dive in I
ain't coming back nudie I want to make
sure before I dive ain't nobody gonna be
trying to take my [__] they're not gonna
take a [__] what do you have I mean they
might listen just don't get scammed
that's what it is you get scammed in
them like there was somebody who spent
like two million dollars to live next to
Snoop Dogg in the fake world
for like a piece of real estate next to
snoop's house yeah and I think I just
saw an article that it's worth like
seventy thousand dollars
that was so that was a robbery right you
know technically he got robbed and he's
like two million dollars reporter for it
he's staying there I don't know though
but but where is he it's it's fake I
don't know none of this it doesn't
matter it literally I think people are
starting to realize Snoop Dogg come in
now to them but he's not live there when
he talks amazing money grab from Snoop
though shout out to him yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah he he did that he did do
that